ist sie das ist das die erste nachricht
von außerirdischem leben
oder das hier
und wenn das wirklich nachrichten von
aliens wären was würden sie bedeuten wie
redet man mit einer fremden lebensformen
die vermutlich in jeglicher hinsicht
komplett anders ist als wir forschende
versuchen schon lange selbst nachrichten
hinaus ins universum zu schicken zentral
ist dabei die suche nach einer
gemeinsamen kommunikationsbasis einige
arbeiten sogar an einer richtigen
universal sprache die überall im weltall
verstanden werden soll aber wie macht
man das und was würden wir anderen
lebensformen überhaupt sagen wollen
[Musik]
also nehmen wir mal an wir haben einen
planeten da draußen entdeckt auf dem es
höchstwahrscheinlich leben gibt dass
dessen bewohner hier morgen vor dem
bundestag landen glaubt wohl niemand
aber woran forschende tatsächlich
arbeiten sind nachrichten die man über
interstellare distanzen an fremde
intelligenzen senden könnte einige
arbeiten sogar an einer universellen
sprache für das universum eine sprache
die alle aliens da draußen verstehen
können sollen aber wie soll das
funktionieren
ist der babel fish aus per anhalter
durch die galaxis gezüchtet worden nun
leider nicht und selbst wenn würde er
wahrscheinlich nicht bei allen aliens
funktionieren denn die probleme in der
trans galaktischen kommunikation fange
schon bei den grundlagen an wir wissen
nicht ob unser gegenüber überhaupt hören
kann überhaupt laute produzieren fühlen
oder sehen kann wir wissen nicht einmal
ob aliens überhaupt die gleichen
fundamentalen konzepte haben wie wir von
zeit vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft von
besitzt und zugehörigkeit oder von
gesellschaften vielleicht ist das leben
auf einem anderen planeten telepathisch
miteinander verbunden und versteht sich
als ein individuum vielleicht lebt
dieses leben nur 30 minuten pro
individuum oder dreitausend jahre das
muss ziemlich nervig sein bei jedem
funkspruch jeweils die menschlichen
enkelkinder des vorgängers daran zu
haben
okay was würden aliens denn auf jeden
fall wissen worauf könnten wir eine
universelle sprache aufbauen erst einmal
ist wichtig dass die wissenschaft sich
nur mit extraterrestrischen zivilisation
beschäftigt die ungefähr unser
intelligenz level oder mehr haben
intergalaktische kommunikation ist so
schon schwierig genug wenn wir dann auch
noch versuchen würden mit blut an den
einzellern zu kommunizieren dann ufer
der aufwand wahrscheinlich irgendwann
aus wir senden also nur nachrichten für
zivilisationen die ein gewisses
technisches
naturwissenschaftliches und
mathematisches grundverständnis haben
und da haben wir dann doch ein paar
gemeinsamkeiten die erste ist die
mathematik denn eins plus eins ist immer
zwei vielleicht haben die aliens tag ein
anderes system für andere namen andere
vorgehensweisen aber man geht davon aus
dass jede intelligente zivilisation
wahrscheinlich mit einem mathe ähnlichen
system arbeitet das mathematik selber
wahrscheinlich universell ist und jedes
halbwegs intelligente wesen ihre
grundzüge erkannt hat für alle
komplexeren mathematischen phänomen da
heißt es dann hoffen dass sie die
gleichen theoreme entwickelt haben es
bleibt also auch hier ein bisschen ein
glücksspiel aber es scheint einer der
erfolgversprechendsten ansätze zu sein
die wir zur verfügung haben fast alle
bisherigen kommunikations versuche
arbeiten mehr oder weniger mit
mathematik zum beispiel mit der
universellen zahl pi oder mit primzahlen
hoffen wir mal dass die aliens
intelligenter sind als ich denn diese
mathematische phänomene hätte ich
wahrscheinlich nicht von alleine
herausgefunden was ich aber ganz von
alleine und nur für euch herausgefunden
habe ist dass nord bpm der sponsor
unseres heutigen videos zehn jahre alt
wird und wie sich das zum zehnjährigen
gehört hat jpm für uns und alle
extraterrestrischen lebensformen mit
internetanschluss ein super angebot
parat
wenn ihr euch mit unserem coach doktor
watson ein 2-jahresabo holt dann bekommt
ihr nicht nur wie üblich einen monat
geschenkt sondern zusätzlich noch ein
ein monats ein ein jahres oder sogar ein
zwei jahres paket obendrauf es gibt also
minimum zwei monate gratis und wenn ihr
glück habt sogar noch mehr jpn ist super
leicht auf smartphone tablet oder
computer installiert und ermöglicht es
euch verschlüsselt mit anderen
lebensformen zu kommunizieren dafür
müsst ihr keine neuen sprache erfinden
außerdem könnt ihr webseiten vorgaukeln
dass ihr in über 60 verschiedenen
ländern seit ihr könnt also ganz bequem
serien und filme wie zum beispiel ins
all wie sunny in philadelphia schauen
die eigentlich nur in den usa verfügbar
sind wie immer gilt nord pn speichert
nicht auf welchen webseiten unterwegs
seid und wenn ihr nicht zufrieden seid
dann habt ihr 30 tage zeit um sich
anders zu überlegen und euer geld zu zu
bekommen live pr.com / doktor watson und
beim checkout den coach doktor watson
benutzen dann bekommt ihr mindestens
zwei monate nur vpn gratis mit etwas
glück sogar noch mehr und damit zurück
zu unserer alvin sprache neben
mathematik gibt es noch eine zweite
sache die aliens wahrscheinlich auch
kennen und das sind atome wasserstoff
sauerstoff gold uran wir gehen davon aus
dass die uns bekannten elemente überall
im universum gleich existieren daher
verwenden mehrere unserer nachrichten an
aliens elemente als maßeinheiten in den
1970 er jahren sind zwei pionier sondern
mit plaketten ausgestattet und ins all
geschickt worden diese plaketten
funktionieren wie eine art visitenkarte
der menschheit und haben vier bereiche
einen der uns menschen zeigt einen der
unsere position in unserem sonnensystem
und den weg der sonne zeigt sowie einen
der unsere position im weltall anhand
der distanz zu einer handvoll pulsaren
zeigt und dann gibt es noch eine art
übersetzungs anleitung und tier ist
wirklich super offensichtlich da sieht
man auf den ersten blick dass das zwei
wasserstoffatome sind und es weiß ja
auch jeder dass dieses atom gelegentlich
seine energie level ändert und beim
hyper feinstruktur übergangen einen
elektromagnetischen impuls von ca 21
zentimeter länge und 0,7 nanosekunden
aussendet grundschul wissen oder ok spaß
beiseite tatsächlich ist das gar nicht
so doof denn dieser impuls ist überall
gleich egal wo du dich im universum
befindest und wasserstoff ist das
element das im universum am häufigsten
vorkommt wenn die aliens also irgendwas
über die naturgesetze wissen ist es gar
nicht so unwahrscheinlich dass sie mit
genau diesen werten vertraut sind daher
verwendet die plakette diese einheit als
längen und zeiteinheit die frau ist zum
beispiel acht dieser wellenlängen groß
also ungefähr ein meter 68 auch die
schallplatten an bord der sonde voyager
1 und 2 die wenige jahre nach dem
pionier sondern gestartet sind arbeiten
mit dieser maßeinheit übrigens die
voyager sonden sind die von menschen
gemachten objekte die am weitesten
draußen im weltall sind die
schallplatten an bord transportieren 116
fotos ton musik und video aufnahmen
sowie begrüßungen in 55 verschiedenen
sprachen und was echt mega intelligent
ist in den voyager sonden ist ein
bisschen radioaktives material
denn die zerfalls geschwindigkeit diese
atome ist ebenfalls universellen anhand
der kleinen probe könnten potenzielle
aliens ermitteln wie alt die sonde ist
egal ob sie die seltsame zeichensprache
auf der platte entschlüsseln konnten
oder nicht eine richtige sprache die
auch komplexe phänomene beschreiben kann
ist das aber natürlich noch nicht geht
da noch mehr die kurze antwort ist ja
die lange antwort nun ja lass es mich
erklären es gab bereits mehrere versuche
mit aliens in kontakt zu treten eine der
bekanntesten interstellaren botschaften
ist die arecibo botschaft sie hat eine
lange reihe aus nullen und einsen also
signalen und nicht signalen ins weltall
gesendet wenn man erkennt dass die
gesamtsumme von diesen 1679 nullen und
einsen das produkt aus beidem primzahlen
23 und 73 ist dann hat man die nachricht
schon zu einem drittel entschlüsselt
wenn man dann auf die idee kommt ein
rechteck mit diesen kantenlänge zu
zeichnen kann man anschließend ganz
bequem mal nach zahlenspielen einzeln
werden ausgemalt 0 in nicht herauskommt
eine stilisierte zeichnung eines
menschen einer dna doppelhelix eines
kohlenstoffatoms und eines teleskops
obviously fun fact hierzu der erfinder
frank drake hat die grundidee mit der
primzahlen und den pixeln zuvor an
kollegen getestet und nur einer von neun
hat die nachricht entschlüsseln können
und das waren alles menschen die
nachricht wurde zwar überarbeitet bevor
sie ins all geschickt wurde aber wer
weiß ob aliens das jemals entschlüsseln
können mal abgesehen davon dass die
chancen sowieso gering stehen dass sie
überhaupt jemand sieht selbst wenn es im
angepeilten sterne cluster mit 4 13
tatsächlich leben geben sollte wird sich
dieses cluster bereits weiter bewegt
haben wenn das signal in 25.000 jahren
beim heutigen standort ankommt
aber auch das was da per funk gesendet
wurde taugt nicht wirklich als sprache
um komplexe ideen zu vermitteln es sind
immer nur informationen die dem
gegenüber wenig darüber sagen was wir
wollen außer vielleicht dass wir reden
wollen
und genau hier hatte der mathematiker
hans freudental um 1960 herum eine
geniale idee was wenn wir nicht einfach
nur unsere nachricht schicken und gut
ist was wenn wir den aliens bevor wir
die eigentliche nachricht schicken erst
stück für stück eine sprache beibringen
quasi einen intergalaktischen sprachkurs
veranstalten englisch und deutsch und
alle menschlichen sprachen eignen sich
hierfür nicht so gut sie brauchen
nämlich kontext und verstanden zu werden
doch eine sprache die auf logik und
mathematik aufbaut sollte auch logisch
ohne weiteren kontext erschlossen werden
können so zumindest die idee von
freudental der daraufhin die sprache
links erfand die ersten nachrichten in
seinem sprachkurs sind dementsprechend
erst mal zahlen 1 blieb für alle 12 für
eine zwei- und so weiter bis das konzept
klar ist dann folgen logisch operatoren
plusminus gleich großer und kleiner ab
anschließend kommen weitere konzepte
hinzu mitmensch plus mensch gleich
mensch könnten wir zum beispiel unsere
fortpflanzung erklären oder mit freunde
größer als feinde unser wertesystem im
laufe dieses sprachkurses sollen so
immer komplexere dinge erklärbar werden
tod leben geldverlust gesetz und so
weiter freudental schlägt vor dass
anhand von beispiel setzen zu machen das
neue wort wird in vielen verschiedenen
kontexten benutzt bis klar wird was
gemeint ist inkludiert in linx könnte
das dann so aussehen hier wird zum
beispiel erklärt dass wir menschen und
tiere auf der oberfläche unseres
planeten leben oder hier wird erklärt
dass unsere zeit relativ ist leider ist
freudenthal mit seiner sprache nie
fertig geworden dennoch hat er uns in
seinem buch link rost design einer
sprache für kosmischen austausch
zahlreiche ausarbeitungen hinterlassen
mit denen wir die einzelteile unserer
welt in einer universellen sprache
beschreiben können das buch ist echt
trocken zu lesen aber trotzdem
wahnsinnig spannend denn es reflektiert
so ein bisschen was man alles über
unsere welt wissen muss um sie zu
verstehen schaut mal rein das ganze
haben wir euch als pdf in der video
beschreibung verlinkt übrigens neben
allen anderen 25 quellen für dieses
video hier und direkt unter dem
like-button
freudental gab allerdings selbst zu dass
der empfänger seiner nachricht zumindest
in grundzügen so logisch denken muss wie
wir dennoch ist diese sprache einen
durchbruch für die außerirdischen
forschung sie kommt einer universellen
sprache des universums schon recht nahe
auf dieser grundlage wurden seitdem
mehrere weitere galaktische sprachen
entwickelt wie zum beispiel cosmic os
sie bringt den aliens mit ähnlichen
strategien die linke alles bei um ein
bestimmtes mit gesendetes
computerprogramm zu nutzen durch
theaterszenen werden ihnen dann
verschiedene aspekte des lebens auf der
erde gezeigt im jahr 1999 sendeten dann
zwei forscher mit hilfe einer sprache
die sie nach dem vorbild von links
aufgebaut hatten einen solchen
sprachkurs an mehrere planeten und der
erste dieser sprachkurse wird
tatsächlich bereits in etwa 13 jahren
ankommen hoffen wir mal dass dann jemand
von anfang bis ende zu hört
[Musik]
ok nehmen wir mal an der
intergalaktische sprachkurs funktioniert
und wir können uns wirklich mit aliens
unterhalten
aber was wollen wir eigentlich sagen
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass
eine zivilisation mit der wir aktuell
reden könnten wahrscheinlich technisch
weiter fortgeschritten wäre als wir denn
eine zivilisation so die annahme
befindet sich nur für einen kurzen
zeitraum in einem status wie wir gerade
technisch fortgeschritten aber noch mit
entwicklungs bedürftiger gesellschaft
irgendwann kommt der sogenannte
flaschenhals die zivilisation geht
entweder an ihre eigenen technischen
entwicklung zugrunde und verschwindet
oder sie wird erwachsen und nun ja
irgendwie weise spoiler dieser
flaschenhals liegt noch vor uns das
doktor watson wettbüro nimmt ab morgen
wetten entgegen zu welcher dieser beiden
gruppen dir gehören werden die
forschenden halten die
wahrscheinlichkeit auf jeden fall für
sehr gering dass es genau jetzt eine
andere zivilisation gibt die ebenfalls
auf dem kurzen entwicklungsstands
zwischen steinzeit und weisheit oder
untergang ist daher ist unser
kommunikationspartner wahrscheinlich
deutlich älter und weiser als wir wir
können also vermutlich viel von den
aliens lernen wie sie so lange überlebt
haben zum beispiel und was rein
menschlich und was tatsächlich universal
gültig ist aber was können wir denn
eigentlich zum interstellaren club der
weissen beitragen dass sich die letzte
staffel von game of thrones nicht lohnt
das eine rapide zunahme von co2 in der
atmosphäre eine blöde idee ist dass die
maske auch über die nase gehört es gibt
tatsächlich ein forschungsprojekt das im
rahmen einer website an die 700
botschaften aus 68 ländern gesammelt hat
die leute gerne an aliens verschicken
würden daraus haben die forschenden
neuen zentrale kategorien von
botschaften entwickelt und hier sind die
top 5 erstens wir sind menschen vom
planeten erde zweitens ihr seid uns
unbekannt aber ihr habt know how
drittens hallo und willkommen
viertens bitte helft uns und fünftens
friede liebe und freundschaft
so geht das nicht es gibt aber auch
forschen wird die der ansicht sind dass
es völlig egal ist was wir funken und ob
die aliens uns verstehen die wichtigste
nachricht käme sowieso immer rüber dass
es uns gibt und dann gibt es noch die
diese ganzen kommunikations versuche
überhaupt nicht lustig finden manche
forschenden glauben dass der kontakt mit
einer anderen zivilisation die uns
wahrscheinlich weit überlegen ist
vermutlich nicht gut ausgehen würde und
wenn man sich mal unsere erdgeschichte
anschaut ist diese sorge nicht ganz
unberechtigt dementsprechend sind diese
forschenden sauer dass einzelne menschen
und organisationen einfach nachrichten
im namen der gesamten menschheit ins
weltall schicken und ich muss sagen
manchmal kann ich sie verstehen 2008 hat
doritos anscheinend werbung ins all
geschickt 2010 wurden die aliens im
klingonisch zu einer klingonischen opa
in den niederlanden eingeladen sollte es
den 17 und 18 wurden sechs nachrichten
von einem spanischen festival in
zusammenarbeit mit dem metier institute
ins ei gesendet und die klangen so
[Musik]
das ist als musik von der erde zu einem
nachbar planeten gesendet worden als
gruß von der menschheit also auch in
unserem namen
kein wunder dass sich darauf keiner
gemeldet hat ich würde die erde auch
dorsten in diesem sinne ich dir damals
klingt echt nicht schön bleibt neugierig
quatsch nicht zu viel mit fremden
lebensformen und vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren